if you keep doing the right thing day
after day
chasing excellence all that stuff why
don't you trust your woman to stay with
you
because i trust women to be women
there's other reasons why women leave
men but primarily it's because of
hypergamy what are the other reasons
i don't have any more kids let's say my
ltr wants to have kids okay
see you later yeah but that's an
incompatibility you can figure out early
on like why can't you have that happily
ever after
did you watch a lot of disney movies
when you're a kid no
you're 32 yeah when did you meet your
boyfriend oh like about five years
ago so were you a virgin when you met
him no okay so i mean you've clearly
slept with other guys so it's not like
you know you're monogamous because
otherwise you'd still be with a guy that
you banged when you were 18.
all relationships have an expiry date i
don't know if your
relationship with your five-year ltr is
going to be this year or in 10 years or
till death do us part a lot of these
women out
out there today are like i'm monogamous
and i'm loyal you'll have me forever and
ever until death do us part yeah right
but the fact still remains well you've
been with
other guys before you got with him